WE ALL SPEND ROUGHLY
A THIRD OF OUR LIVES ASLEEP
ACCESSING DREAM WORLDS IN OUR SUBCONSCIOUS
THAT ARE LOST BY THE TIME WE WAKE UP.
BUT WHAT IF THEY DIDN’T HAVE TO BE?
JUDITH AMORES AND THE ENGINEERS, NEUROSCIENTISTS, AND DESIGNERS SHE WORKS WITH
AT MIT’S MEDIA LAB,
DUBBED “THE DREAM TEAM,"
ARE WORKING TO DECODE THE UNCONSCIOUS MIND.
BUT THESE ARE NO ORDINARY SLEEP SCIENTISTS.
THEY DON’T JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE ROLE
THAT SLEEP AND DREAMS CAN PLAY IN OUR LIVES;
THEY THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY TINKER WITH IT.
SLEEP HAS LONG BEEN RECOGNIZED
NOT ONLY FOR BEING THERAPEUTIC,
BUT ALSO A SOURCE OF INSPIRATION.
VISIONARIES LIKE NIKOLA TESLA
HAVE USED HYPNAGOGIA,
THE STATE OF BEING HALF ASLEEP,
TO DOZE THEIR WAY TO SOME
OF THE WORLD’S MOST ICONIC
ART AND INVENTIONS.
TO HARNESS THIS POTENTIAL,
THE DREAM TEAM IS EXPLORING
THE WORLD OF ‘HUMAN-MACHINE SYMBIOSIS...’
THAT IS, DESIGNING TECHNOLOGY
INTENDED FOR SEAMLESS INTEGRATION
INTO YOUR LIFE... AND YOUR BODY.
AND IF THAT SOUNDS STRAIGHT OUT OF SCI-FI…
IT IS.
THE DREAM TEAM RECENTLY DEBUTED DORMIO,
A GLOVE DESIGNED TO BOOST CREATIVITY.
DORMIO RECOGNIZES A HYPNAGOGIC STATE,
TRIGGERS A ROBOTIC VOICE TO READ YOU
AN AUDIO CUE OR CREATIVE PROMPT
IN YOUR SLEEP, AND RECORDS
YOUR MUMBLED RESPONSE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT OUR SLEEP STATES
BEYOND HYPNAGOGIA?
THE DREAM TEAM IS DEVELOPING
ADDITIONAL PROTOTYPES
TO ANALYZE EVEN MORE OF
YOUR BODY’S BIOLOGICAL CUES.
A DEEP LEARNING COMPUTER MODEL THEN DECIPHERS THIS INFORMATION
TO DETERMINE WHAT STAGE
OF SLEEP A PERSON IS IN.
TARGETING ONE OR MORE OF THESE SLEEP STAGES
COULD BE LIKE FINDING THE SECRET ENTRANCE
TO YOUR OWN SUBCONSCIOUS.
THE CHALLENGE IS ACTUALLY OPENING THAT DOOR
WITHOUT WAKING YOU UP.
SO THE DREAM TEAM IS ON THE HUNT FOR SIGNALS
OR STIMULI THAT CAN DO JUST THAT.
AND JUDITH HAS SNIFFED OUT A PARTICULARLY
USEFUL TOOL: OUR SENSE OF SMELL.
DURING YOUR SLEEP, THIS DEVICE COULD
BE PROGRAMMED TO RELEASE A SCENT
FAMILIAR TO YOU, THAT YOU’VE ALREADY ASSOCIATED WITH A LEARNED BEHAVIOR
SUCH AS SMELLING ROSE WHILE YOU
STUDY A NEW LANGUAGE.
THE TOYS AND TOOLS DREAMED UP
IN THE MEDIA LAB ARE USUALLY
CONTROLLED BY A SIMPLE SMARTPHONE APP,
MAKING IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE
TO GET THE RESULTS THEY WANT
WHETHER IT’S FACING YOUR FEARS
IN A DREAM, BREAKING A BAD HABIT,
OR JUST GETTING A BETTER NIGHT’S REST.
AND FOR JUDITH AND HER TEAM, PAVING THE WAY
FOR THAT MUTUAL SYMBIOSIS WITH TECHNOLOGY
IS WHAT THE FUTURE IS ALL ABOUT.
THIS EPISODE WAS PRESENTED
BY THE U.S. AIR FORCE.
LEARN MORE AT AIRFORCE.COM.
FOR MORE EPISODES OF SCIENCE IN THE EXTREMES,
CHECK OUT THIS ONE RIGHT HERE.
DON'T FORGET TO SUBSCRIBE,
AND COME BACK TO SEEKER FOR MORE EPISODES.
THANKS FOR WATCHING!